allez nous poursuivons par une question
de notre collègue monsieur alain fouché
pour le groupe des républicains
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture
après la révélation de nouveaux cas de
maltraitance animale le doute sinon la
prob la propre et jetés sur les 263
abattoirs que compte la france
interrogé ici même en novembre dernier
vous aviez affirmé
l'état contrôle et continuera à
contrôler les abattoirs et a renforcé
ses contrôles
cent quatre avertissements et 70 en
demeure avaient été adressées aux
abattoirs au cours de l'année 2014
vous aviez également promis le
recrutement d'ici 2017 260 postes dans
les services vétérinaires
confronté à de nouveaux cas de
maltraitance je devais demander
aujourd'hui au préfet de faire réaliser
dans un délai d'un mois
des inspections spécifique dans tous les
abattoirs nature à nantes où sera clean
durant ce mois mais après c'est là la
question vous annoncer également la
présence de représentants pour la
protection animale désignés au sein des
salariés des abattoirs de pointe
bénéficiant d'un statut protecteur il
existe déjà notamment à mauléon licharre
on a pu en constater l'efficacité
il s'agit de redonner confiance aux
éleveurs et aux consommateurs la
protection animale doit être prise en
considération au même titre que les
conditions sanitaires et des conditions
de travail de ses salariés
quelles mesures comptez-vous prendre
monsieur le ministre pour faire cesser
ce scandale
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll ministre de l'agriculture ce
président le sénateur vous avez évoqué
des images qui ont été publiés dans
plusieurs télévisions suite à des prises
de vue de l'association el 204 et vous
avez rappelé des propos qui étaient les
miens je veux d'abord rappelé que dès le
mois de mai 2014
j'ai demandé à des gels de mettre en
place une stratégie sur le bien-être
animal de manière globale
conscient que ce sujet n'est pas un
sujet qu'il faut traiter simplement avec
l'actualité je rappelle d'ailleurs
qu'ici au céda nous avons voté un
certain nombre de mesures dans le cadre
de la loi d'avenir qui permettent la
transparence sur toutes les publications
qui sont faites par les services de
l'état
mais vous avez rappelé effectivement que
263 abattoirs ce contrôle et la
responsabilité d'état est engagée
je vais juste vous dire par rapport à ce
débat sur le nombre de fonctionnaires
est vétérinaire que oui ce gouvernement
va créer 60 vétérinaire supplémentaires
en 2015 60 en 2016 60 en 2010 780
supplémentaire et je veux le dire quand
même là aussi quand je suis arrivé
c'était 440 emplois de vétérinaire qui
avait été supprimé donc on ne va pas
encore rattrapé ce que vous aviez su
priver et je le dis d'ailleurs et je
vous le dit monsieur le sénateur dans
les débats qui animent l'opposition
quand j'entends qu'on va supprimer 300
mille fonctionnaires
je vous demande là de bien prendre en
compte ce type de propositions que vous
faites
parce que sur chaque sujet vous allez
avoir des difficultés à nous dire
comment vous allez faire à partir de là
moi je vais assumer ma responsabilité
mais vous l'avez dit cette
responsabilité doit être partagée
j'ai trop entendu est trop souvent le
fait qu' il revient à l'état d'assurer
la totalité du suivi sur le bien-être
animal dans les abattoirs en particulier
ça ne revient pas en totalité à l'état
ça revient aussi à un système de ton
contrôle et de responsabilité partagées
d'où le représentant sur la protection
animale
d'où un statut nouveau qui lui sera
donnée parce que c'est vrai qu'ils ont
existé mais si les salariés ont peur de
perdre leur emploi vous pensez bien
qu'ils vont pas dénoncé les mauvais
traitements qui sont produits dans les
abattoirs et deuxième point au delà des
salariés parce que moi je me mets aussi
à la place de ceux qui travaillent dans
les abattoirs travail pénible et c'est
pourquoi je défends aussi la pénibilité
au niveau de la retraite que certains
contestent aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
aussi à respecter ce travail des
salariés sur les salariés
je préfère qu'on ait aussi la
responsabilité de l'encadrement et des
directeurs d'abattoirs et y aura donc un
délit pénal qui sera mis en
dans la loi sapin au mois de juin pour
faire en sorte que chacun se sente
responsabilité j ajoute dans le plan et
la stratégie sur le bien-être animal des
innovations techniques
j'en donnais une qui va se mettre en
oeuvre sur le sexage des poussins on a
suffi en vue des images atroces sur le
broyage des poussins la france sera le
premier pays à mettre en oeuvre une
innovation qui permettra à ceux sexage
in dans l'oeuf
alors qu'aujourd'hui il est fait comme
vous l'avez pu le constater la france
innove
la france avance et sur ce plan nous
sommes en avance au niveau européen
monsieur alain boucher pour répliquer à
monsieur le millier je suis ministre
simplement je rappelle moi aussi qu'il
ya quatre ans que vous êtes au pouvoir
bonjour appelle aussi que l'article 521
1 du code pénal vous pouvez vous
renseigner auprès de votre collègue
réprimer les actes de cruauté simplement
je voudrais que vous écoutiez un certain
nombre de propositions qui ont été
faites par le syndicat national des
inspecteurs en santé publique
vétérinaire qui paraissent utiles
renforcement des contrôles vétérinaires
mise en place des caméras au niveau des
postes de saignée dans tous les
abattoirs mise en place de comités
d'éthique dans les abattoirs composé de
représentants des éleveurs bouchers
associations de défense des animaux des
mérites société civile comme cela existe
déjà dans les laboratoires qui
pratiquent des expériences sur les
animaux
je crois qu'il faudrait que vous
écoutiez ces propositions allaient